listening to a film courage women
Raven and ki reward
they dropped out of college and I'm
doing community organizing and working
really long hours and when I got used to
working a hundred hour work week and you
know not making enough money to do very
much and not wanting to just go to you
know some bar in some town and drink and
I started going to see movies is the way
to unwind and really was watching
probably three or four movies a week and
not great movies but really loving the
experience of sitting in the dark and
you know getting getting encompassed you
know by that that that story leaving
myself and you know the only way that I
could get my mind off of you know how
much work i had entire me to get done
and those those who really like this i
think that the driving forces where it
felt like movie got movies got onto my
skin it it wasn't what i originally was
going to do but i felt as a young man
that the film business was very closed
industry that you know it would be very
hard to engage in it without having you
know money of my own i came from very
modest means and um you know it felt
like we spoke a whole other language and
even when i went to film school it felt
that what was being initially taught to
me wasn't something that I had access to
but I had the good fortune of moving to
New York City jess's the you know what
is frequently referred to as the the you
know American independent wave was
taking hold